je rappelle que cette commission
denquête a été constitué à la demande du
groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains et à pourra porter david
assouline
mesdames messieurs il nous a semblé
important avec le rapporteur de
consacrer une audition complète au
service public que vous représentez dans
sa diversité la france dispose d'un
service public de l'audiovisuel qui
représentent une part importante du
marché ainsi le groupe france
télévisions rassemble une part
d'audience de plus de 28% en 2021 et
arte à peu près 3% radio france de son
côté est le groupe leader en france avec
près de 30% de parts de marché il était
donc difficile de parler de
concentration des médias sans réunir un
service public qui par bien des égards
en est un acteur dominant pour autant et
s'il est pour certains paré de toutes
les vertus le service public est
également parfois victime de suspicion
ou d'interrogation quant à son
indépendance du pouvoir politique soit
une remarque exactement symétrique à
celle des médias privés face au pouvoir
économique de leurs actionnaires nous
souhaitons donc vous entendre à la fois
pour une réflexion générale sur la
concentration des médias un mouvement
qui pourrait encore être accentués en
2022 avec le projet de rapprochement tf1
m6 ou la montée en puissance de vivendi
mais également sur ce qui fait selon
vous la spécificité d'un média de
service public et les garanties qu'ils
présentent face aux risques d'ingérences
je vous propose l'organisation sue
suivante qui est dans la droite ligne de
l'ensemble des de celles que nous avons
mises en place pour l'heure les
différentes auditions à savoir je vais
vous laisser la parole pendant huit
minutes chacun pour un propos liminaire
je serais assez vigilant sur le respect
du temps de parole tout simplement pour
que nous puissions par la suite vous
poser des questions et c'est le
rapporteur bien entendu qui commencera
la première série de questions je vous
précise que cette audition est diffusé
sur le site internet du sénat et qu'elle
fera également l'objet d'un compte rendu
qui sera publié enfin je rappelle pour
la forme d'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d' enquête
seraient passibles des peines prévues
aux articles 434 13 14 et 15 du code
pénal je précise également qu'il vous
appartient le cas échéant d'indiquer vos
éventuels liens d'intérêts ou conflits
d'intérêts en relation avec l'objet de
la commission denquête je vais vous
inviter à la mer note madame payet
monsieur patino a prêté serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure la mer note
savez
j'ai patino merci je vous laisse la
parole donc pour une minute je ne sais
pas qui commence d'ailleurs note salée
voilà je pense que j'ai trouv parce que
vous me permettez dans les mangas
cependant que je parle ou pas non je
vois qu'à votre regard que non je garde
de le dire qui effectivement très bien
très bien très bien faire
merci monsieur le président ce cette
commission denquête arrive dans un
moment où on sent une forme de
cristallisation de l'inquiétude sur la
tenue du débat public et c'est vrai
qu'on constate aujourd'hui que trois
français sur quatre ne disent plus avoir
avoir eu non plus il est clair de
l'actualité ça tient sans doute à trois
facteurs d'abord la prédominance des
réseaux sociaux et le fait qu'une fausse
information circule six fois plus vite
qu'une information juste ces réseaux
sociaux nous enfermant des boucles qui
finalement nous
nous nous confortent dans des opinions
qu'on peut déjà avoir sans parler de la
dérive du harcèlement en ligne qu on
peut aussi observer dans le même temps
et des chaînes d'opinion qui émerge avec
leur lot d'historisation du débat et de
culture du clash
finalement ce qu'on admet au fond dans
la presse des médias des titres qui
porte une opinion est assez nouveau dans
la télévision française tout ça dans un
secteur qui se consomme très vite en
france comme ailleurs en europe en
france le rachat de lagardère le projet
de fusion tf1 m6 donc la question de la
concentration se pose dans un moment de
dérèglements médiatique est pour moi le
questionne deux choses d'abord le
pluralisme et enfin la diversité
culturelle
ma première conviction c'est que le
service public est une balise
indispensable pour les sites web en
matière d'information parce que dans ce
moment de dérèglement climatique
médiatique pardon
l'information chez nous dans le service
public n'est pas une marchandise
mais la base du contrat de confiance
qu'on a avec nos concitoyens d'abord
parce que nous sommes indépendants des
pouvoirs économiques et des pouvoirs
politiques parce que pluralisme et de
coeur de nos offres parce que nous avons
ce contrat de confiance qui s'inscrit
qui se voit dans les différentes
enquêtes on notera que france info
qu'est notre commune est largement en
tête en termes de confiance des chaînes
d'information et puis parce que nous
avons dans le service public une offre
d'investigation qui est désormais unique
on fait d'ailleurs en europe une
corrélation très stricte entre le poids
des services publics la santé les
services publics et le niveau de
démocratie des différents pays quand je
dis corrélation ses leçons scientifique
au scientifique du terme et dans ce
contexte on a des propositions de
privatisation
ou d'abandon du service une partie du
service public en france en grande
bretagne également c'est dans le débat
pour moi qui est en fait d'un autre
siècle et qui voudrait qu'on passe d'un
monopole public dans les années 80 une
forme de monopole privé dans les années
2020 et au delà
ma deuxième conviction c'est que les
médias nationaux rester vont rester
durablement les principaux financeurs de
la création française
on voit le pouvoir des médias globaux
transnationaux d'origine américaine
aujourd'hui asiatique sûrement demain
dans le top 10 le top 10 des géants de
la tech représente 30 x 30 x la valeur
des 66 médias de service public européen
donc je vais vous dire le poids de ces
médias globaux
ils ont une force politique très
importante on le voit aujourd'hui à
bruxelles puisqu'il oeuvre contre le
projet de dessin de digital s'invite l'
acte porté par là par la commission et
puis évidemment tout technologique
puisque tous les terminaux sont non
européens les algorithmes sont non
européens cette situation nous fragile
lise un moment où nous subissons des
bases budgétaires dans le service public
est une forme de tension aussi sur le
marché de la publicité pour les chaînes
privées on voit une forme d'emprise sur
les talents je cite souvent cet exemple
mais fanny herrero qui est la très
grande chevreuse de 10% est sous contrat
chez netflix et donc ne peut plus
travailler pour quelqu'un d'autre omar
sy encore récemment et puis on voit dans
des domaines connexes comme les droits
du sport que ces grandes plates formes
américaines viennent maintenant aussi
arracher les droits sportifs la ligue 1
roland garros pour amazon
les acteurs européens doivent se
renforcer pour faire face à cela c'est
une position qui vaut pour l'audiovisuel
privé c'est pour ça que je me suis
toujours déclarés en faveur de la fusion
tf1 m6 comme pour l'audiovisuel public
nous avons de nombreuses alliances une
union lui er qui nous qui nous rassemble
des offres communes jean site est une
tout à l'heure qui est france info mais
d'autres sur lesquelles nous sommes en
chantier notamment avec ma collègue
sybille et puis aussi des alliances au
niveau européen à la fois dans la
défense de nos intérêts communs
public privé d'ailleurs puisque nous
avons une posture commune public privé
en matière de soutien aux déesses a et o
dm1 qui sont les deux textes aujourd'hui
à bruxelles
enfin ma troisième conviction dans ce
dilemme
concentration versus pluralisme c'est
qu'il ya un chemin ténu mais qui existe
la première chose c'est de mettre la
question du pluralisme de l'information
au coeur des préoccupations dans les
grands projets de rapprochement
et pour ce faire nous avons c'est très
certainement besoin de nous appuyer sur
un régulateur fort l'art comme qui
prendra en compte cette question de
façon centrale
la deuxième conte la deuxième conviction
pour résoudre ce dilemme c'est de
défendre un service public fort
indépendant et accessible à tous il ya
évidemment urgence à réformer la
redevance puisque en 2023 la question se
pose déjà et nous devons comme nous le
faisons aujourd'hui avec mes collègues
accélérer les coopérations entre
services publics français notamment sur
le numérique pour massifier notre offre
être visible c'est un enjeu pour nous
mêmes deux puissances et puis le dernier
point qui n'est pas encore totalement
traité mais qui est très très important
c'est la prééminence c'est à dire
comment est ce que les services publics
notamment mais pas que les grands
services privés aussi reste des contenus
d'intérêt général et existe dans ces
environnements numériques que nous ne
maîtrisons pas pour éviter
l'effacement technologique comment
demain quand on ouvrira un allumera une
télévision connectée on aura accès aux
applications des services publics
comment demain on peut imaginer un
bouton service public sur la
télécommande là où aujourd'hui vous avez
un beau tour netflix et un bouton disney
je vous remercie
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur a tout d'abord merci beaucoup
de nous réunir pour parler d'un sujet
qui est important qui concerne
l'évolution de l'écosystème des médias
et des impacts qu'ils assurent notamment
sur le débat public et je vous en
remercie parce que je pense que ça
permet de prendre le sujet des médias
par là où il doit être pris à un moment
où on a été distrait de pas mal de
questions par des critiques faites à
l'encontre du service public qui a été
paradoxalement c'est le critique était
paradoxalement mise à l'agenda
médiatique et politique précisément à un
moment où son utilité n'a sans doute
jamais été aussi forte et où sa
reconnaissance par le public n'avait
jamais été aussi importante puisque nous
n'avons jamais eu par exemple autant
d'auditeurs à radio france que depuis
ces dernières années
alors de nombreuses sont les personnes
auditionnées devant votre commission qui
ont rappelé l'évolution des usages la
concurrence internationale qui constitue
une nouvelle donne du secteur
audiovisuel et qui dans ce contexte fond
de la consolidation d'acteurs nationaux
à mouvement qui apparaît logique au
niveau français et européen
cette concentration a évidemment des
avantages des effets d'échelle de masse
critique est là aussi on le sait des
inconvénients qui eux ne sont pas
automatiques sur les salaires sur les
prix la diversité
ce qu'on voit c'est que des acteurs très
innovant mais de taille réduite ou sur
des segments restera peuvent être aussi
performant également que des mastodontes
multimétiers eux peuvent se confronter à
l'échec quand ils oublient d'être et
nous donc je pense que dans une économie
ouverte dans laquelle nous vivons le
législateur doit avoir avant tout à
coeur d'aider les acteurs être
performant quelle que soit leur taille
pourvu que la diversité l'innovation et
d'indépendance soit garanti
ça concerne tout autant le secteur de la
vidéo dont on parle beaucoup que les
acteurs de l'audio tout on parle moi et
nous avons besoin d'acteurs forts et
émouvants de chaque côté pour contrer
d'un côté netflix et les autres
plateformes de vidéos est contrée de
l'autre spotify apple amazon musique par
exemple pour le secteur de la radio et
de la musique où il ya de nouveaux
acteurs qui viennent aussi je pense que
c'est important et c'est le message que
j'aimerais vraiment faire passer devant
deux commissions il faut sortir l'audio
de l'oubli et c'est sur ce sujet
peut-être spécifique que je voudrais
peut-être apporter un éclairage
complémentaire devant votre commission
dans le monde actuel no conclure on a
nous radio france se sont plus
simplement rtl europe 1 rmc nrj se sont
aujourd'hui spotify amazon apple amazon
qui par exemple lance son offre de
podcasts en france et on sait combien le
rapport des jeunes à la musique le
rapport des jeunes à l'audio parler ce
qu'on appelle les podcasts aujourd'hui à
changer il passe beaucoup plus de temps
à streamés sur des plateformes par
exemple qu'à aller vers des médias
traditionnels ce qui veut dire qu'il est
essentiel aujourd'hui d'investir dans
l'innovation dans ce nouveau secteur
audio pour préserver une forme de
souveraineté culturelle et je parle bien
de souveraineté culturelle parce sinon
comment se résigner à ce que dans dix
ans les jeunes en france n'écoute plus
aucun artiste français si on n'a pas
d'acteur de l'audio en france qui soit
fort et qui promeuvent toute la
diversité et la richesse de la musique
en france c'est soit quoi on risque
d'aboutir parce que sur les plates
formes de streaming les algorithmes ne
sont pas conçus monde là pour pousser
les des artistes français ou la
diversité ça implique donc d'avoir des
acteurs nationaux qui soit fort et vous
avez un service public sur lequel vous
pouvez compter qui porte ce sujet de
soutien de la diversité culturelle et de
l'exception culturelle française à bras
le corps depuis le suit présente de
radio france j'ai fait deux choix
stratégique d'une part remettent l'audio
au coeur de notre stratégie et de nos
investissements au moment où il y avait
beaucoup débat d'ailleurs sur
l'importance d'associer ou pas de
l'image et de la vidéo et l'apparition
justement de ces nouveaux acteurs de
l'audio qui sont des acteurs mondiaux
sur le podcast et la musique nous a
donné raison
deuxième choix que j'ai fait c'est
réduire notre dépendance aux grands
agrégateurs en matière de distribution
numérique
quand j'ai pris mes fonctions en 2010 84
% de nos podcasts était écoutée sur des
plateformes des agrégateurs qui était
anglo-saxon en fin d'année dernière donc
fin 2021 notre application radio france
qui est une application 100% audio avait
plus d'utilisateurs mensuels qu'apple
podcast c'est pour vous dire le chemin
on a réussi à parcourir qui est un
accomplissement y mange quand on sait la
disproportion de force et deux moyens
qui a entre un acteur comme apple est un
acteur comme le la radio de service
public en france
s'appuie évidemment sur nos contenus
s'appuie aussi sur les investissements
qu'il faut faire dans l'ergonomie
l'expérience utilisateur
les plateformes là toute la technologie
qui est nécessaire au jeu aujourd'hui
pour s'adapter aux nouveaux usages et
j'irai même que les médias historiques
qui n'engage pas cette mutation sont
condamnés progressivement à disparaître
des usages des français en commençant
par ceux des plus jeunes générations
or nous
là je parle des acteurs de la radio et
radio france on a besoin qui est des
acteurs de la radio et de l'audio qui
soient forts des acteurs qui soient
aussi nature privée pour entretenir
l'intérêt du public pour le média radio
donc oui à la consolidation d'acteurs
qui soit force elle permet aux acteurs
de la radio d'engager leur mutation vers
l'audio or ce que je peux constater
c'est que ces dernières années les
différents rapprochements multimédia à
l'oeuvre ce sont pour beaucoup fait au
détriment de ce média au sein de groupes
radio télé on observe que la radio est
rarement tiré vers l'eau dans les choix
d'investissement je donnais un exemple
très simple c'est celui de vue des abbés
plus
nous sommes nous avons été en france en
très grand retard par rapport à nos
voisins européens sur le déploiement
cette nouvelle technologie de diffusion
de la radio nous l'avons été parce que
ce n'est pas un investissement qui a été
priorisé par les différents acteurs de
la radio or continuer à écouter la radio
sur une technologie la technologie efm
qui date des années 40 est ce le
meilleur moyen de rendre ce média encore
attractifs pour les plus jeunes
générations
et heureusement qu'avec la persévérance
d'une part de l'art comme anciennement
cessa de la radio publique française et
d'autres acteurs nous avons vraiment
fait en sorte que le virage vers le
diable et plus soit engagée que
l'ensemble des acteurs s'y engage pour
qu'on rattrape le retard pris sur les
autres pays européens en matière de
diffusion de cette nouvelle technologie
qui aujourd'hui est poussé dans beaucoup
d'autres pays européens
le royaume uni par exemple récemment qui
a dit qu'ils envisageaient d'ici 2030 le
basculement de toute la diffusion dans
cette technologie
alors par ailleurs j'observe que souvent
les rapprochements entre offres radio
france télévisions se font dans une
logique de synergie de coûts de couplage
d'offres publicitaires en diffusant le
même programme sur les deux médias et ça
se traduit par un appauvrissement de la
diversité des contenus qu'on l'a vous
aviez deux contenus vous n'en avez plus
qu un
et d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour
laquelle les projets de coopération que
nous avons développées au sein du giec
publics etc avec delphine des projets
qui nous anime et dans lesquels nous
croyons beaucoup à chaque fois nous
avons fait en sorte que ce ne soit pas
pour supprimer une offre existante qui
réduisent la diversité mais bien pour
créer une offre supplémentaire nouvelle
qui soit vraiment utile pour les
citoyens par exemple offre nouvelle de
france info est une offre où il ya une
nouvelle chaîne de télévision une
nouvelle offre ni titre qui ont été
créés en adjoignant les forces de la
radio et la télévision publiques ce que
nous faisons entre france bleu et france
3 vise à faire en sorte cher delphine
d'avoir une offre régionale de france 3
qui s'accroissent grâce à l'apport
complémentaire peut avoir la rade donc
ça a été à chaque fois pour apporter de
nouvelles offres qui correspondent à un
besoin à une utilité pour le public et
pour le citoyen on s'est vraiment
attachés à chaque fois à jouer sur la
force de chacun des médias et surtout
aussi sur l'effet démultiplicateur que
peuvent avoir voilà le projet numérique
qui a sous-tendu ses principales offres
la seconde réflexion je voulais partager
avec vous
les différents médias sur cette question
parce que quand il ya le soupçon ça
entache l'ensemble du secteur
or le paysage de l'information s'est
transformée et aujourd'hui pour faire
une information de qualité ça demande
des moyens qui sont très importants
toujours des moyens de reportages des
enquêtes de l'investigation pour ne pas
se limiter à des débats sur les plateaux
et orale et de polémiques nées sur les
réseaux sociaux pour faire du buzz face
ils ont fait un travail de fond qui est
un travail important pour construire une
réponse globale face à la transformation
du paysage de l'information un exemple
on investit par exemple dans
l'intelligence artificielle donc ce sont
là autant de questions qui font qu'on
prend à bras le corps cette
problématique de la diffusion de fausses
informations et la bataille pour la
fiabilité de l'information c'est
cette audition
pardon j'ai coupé votre micro
ouais
merci madame la présidente on va te sans
revenir sur les points que vous n'avez
pas pu aborder à travers nos questions
et pas de doute monsieur patino oui
monsieur le président merci beaucoup je
vais essayer d'être rapide d'autant plus
que je ne peux que m'inscrire dans la
continuité de ce qui a été dit à la fois
par delphine ernotte et sur la nécessité
du service public épars et par sybille
vesle sur sa nécessité d'innover
là-dessus arte est totalement ce comme
sur beaucoup d'autres choses en accord
avec ce qui vient d'être dit je le dis
d'autant plus que comme pour reprendre
les termes de delphine ernotte ou de
sybille vesle
sûr parfois les questionnements qui se
font par rapport au service public au
rôle du service public ou au poids du
service public vous le savez arte est
une chaîne franco-allemande et que nous
vivons donc avec si j'ose dire l'écho ou
la stéréo de nos amis allemands et qu'en
allemagne en juillet le tribunal
constitutionnel de karlsruhe tout en
validant une augmentation de la
redevance en allemagne a rappelé à quel
point plus que jamais le service public
était une nécessité pour la démocratie
allemande dans un moment où l'espace
public tend à se polariser et se
fragmenter et donc il a à la fois ce
tribunal permis l audiovisuel public
allemand d'avoir plus de ressources que
jamais dans son histoire est par
ailleurs plus de devoirs si je veux dire
c'est à dire des devoirs évidemment qui
sont des devoirs civiques public et
d'intérêt général alors juste pour
compléter ou peut-être juste être en
écho avec ce qui a été dit par la
présidente de france télévisions et
celle de radio france trois petites
réflexions est une illustration
évidemment le cadre sur la concentration
des médias la loi de 86 c'est un moment
où le cadre a été fait dans un an dans
un moment où il existait une certaine
rareté des médias et se pose la question
aujourd'hui de quel cadre dans un monde
de profusion alors qu'il ya jamais eu
autant d'image autant de sont autant de
chaînes de télévision pour autant qu'on
soit capable de définir encore ce qu est
une chaîne de télévision autant de
plateformes vidéos etc etc on voit bien
que dans ce monde de la profusion en
tout cas nous le vivons comme ça le les
lieux j'allais dire de tensions y
compris en termes de pluralisme de
diversité se sont déplacés des deux dans
les deux extrêmes de la chaîne de valeur
d'un côté dans l'accès à l'information à
la propriété intellectuelle au talent
aux créateurs ce qu'a dit delphine
ernotte concernant évidemment l'est
notre dialogue je mets des guillemets
avec les plateformes est tout à fait
vrai et vraiment je je m'y associe
absolument pleinement mais de l'autre
aussi ça s'est déplacé en aval avec ce
qu'on peut appeler la découvrabilité
c'est-à-dire non plus la capacité de
mettre à disposition mais la capacité de
faire découvrir et le poids ou la
puissance aujourd'hui elle se situe dans
la capacité à faire découvrir est ce
qu'à dit 6020 il est tout à fait juste
faire découvrir c'est une question
technologique c'est une question qui
pousse à l'innovation et qui poussent
aux moyens technologiques à la main à la
maîtrise de la data et donc je si vous
me le permettez cette expression informé
aujourd'hui
rendre accessible la culture
crée un espace public c'est aussi un
enjeu technologique et souhaite aussi un
défi technologique
on voit bien dans alors ça ne rend pas
obsolète évidemment les analyses de
concentration j'allais dire par secteur
ou en silo mais en tout cas elle ne sont
plus du tout suffisante aujourd'hui si
je dois juste en 30 secondes
à faire un cran encore au delà on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui on a plusieurs
modèles économiques qui existent dans
l'univers des médias qui ont chacun une
conséquence sur l'espace public et sur
l'information et sur notre vie
culturelle en général il ya le modèle de
l'économie de l'attention publicitaires
qu'ils soient numériques ou ou
télévisuelles ou radiophoniques et là
évidemment on est sur la soupe sur
sollicitation de l'audience avec les
mécanismes que ça veut dire il ya la
deuxième modèle qui est l'économie
d'adhésion ça c'est l'abonnement
abonnement qui peut être très qualitatif
ou moins qualitative qui peut être de
presse qui peut être autre mais le
modèle de l'économie de l'adhésion et
bien ça archives élise votre public un
moment ou un autre c'est pas négatif
mais ça crée des chapelles de fidélité
et puis il ya un troisième modèle qui
est le modèle du service public et ce
modèle du service public à mon sens
c'est le seul modèle qui essaye de
rassembler qui soit mû par l'intérêt
général c'est le seul modèle dont
l'objet est de transformer le public en
citoyens et c'est pour ça que je pense
que vraiment en 2022 un discours ou un
dialogue sur la concentration la
problème de la conversion de la
concentration de la diversité c'est
aussi s'assurer d'une diversité des
modèles économiques pour chaque média
donc la présence d'un service public
fort à côté des privés qui se fou qui se
finance sur la publicité ou des privés
qui se financent par l'abonnement est
par ailleurs au sein même de ces modèles
économiques et une diversité des acteurs
dans chacun des modèles économiques qui
est pas qu'un seul acteur publicitaire
qui n'est pas qu'un seul acteur
d'abonnement y compris quand on parle
des plateformes et qui est une pluralité
dans l'offre des organismes de service
public tout ça vous le savez déjà donc
j'en parle très très rapidement juste
pour vous dire que on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde recherche
de nouveaux critères sur la
concentration
vous rappelez peut-être ce qui se passe
en allemagne à la fois dans les règles
qui me semble extrêmement moderne est
évidemment dans les critères qui peuvent
apparaître comme déjà un peu dépassé je
vais essayer pas dépasser mais huit
minutes monsieur le président je vous
promets une règle pour un rappel en
allemagne le rappel du tabou une gueule
berg alfred jung berg était le forge
time for this tender de krupp pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale il a et même
pendant les la création du nazisme est
donc évidemment depuis il y à ce tabou
qui existe en allemagne et qui proscrit
absolument l'adossement des médias à une
industrie c'est une règle structurelles
dans le dans le cas également alors il
ya évidemment un côté positif à cela un
côté entre guillemets en termes de
concentration de conséquence c'est que
ça crée des grands groupes médias qui
évidemment pousse à la concentration des
groupes médias eux mêmes mais sinon ce
qui peut peut-être vous intéressait
aussi c'est que il y a deux maillage ou
de niveau comme toujours en allemagne de
calcul sur le poids qu'on peut avoir un
moment donné en termes de concentration
au niveau des länder
on essaye d'étudier les positions
dominantes dans la fabrication de
l'opinion
donc les länder les quatorze bureaux des
länder qui sont en charge de l'analyse
de la de la concentration des médias
regarde le poids dans l'opinion est
alors pour le moment c'est calculé de
façon j'allais dire assez traditionnel
par les parts d'audience
mais rien dans le fonctionnement des
länder ne les oblige à rester sur cette
analyse de part d'audience c'est à dire
que les critères peuvent évoluer le
deuxième chose c'est le niveau de l'état
fédéral et la l'état fédéral s'intéresse
aux médias comme marché est donc là on
en revient sur un système beaucoup plus
traditionnelle de parts de marché dans
une danse un silo ou des industries
données
voilà pour l'illustration allemande pour
terminer évidemment plaidé ou illustrer
ce qu'on essaye de faire je crois qu'il
ya beaucoup de modèles qui existent
aujourd'hui et que le problème de la
concentration telle qu'on la voit
arriver partout c'est à dire le
gigantisme petit à petit ça trois
conséquences qui peuvent être à un
moment donné on va dire à étudier le
premier c'est que souvent on confond les
économies d'échelle les effets de réseau
ce qui a été très bien dit par les deux
présidentes de france télévisions et de
radio france et que les effets de réseau
c'est des effets j'allais dire
d'efficacité sur le réseau ça peut venir
aussi d'acteurs petit ça suppose une
agilité et une très grande capacité
d'innovation technologique alors que les
économies d'échelle
c'est une vision industrielle déjà de
cosco tient ou autres d'une d'un monde
déjà pour ma part en tout cas un petit
peu dépassé
la deuxième chose c'est la
mondialisation des marchés qui fait qu'à
un moment donné on peut avoir des effets
d'éviction
éviction par rapport aux créateurs mais
ne vous y trompez pas l'éviction en
termes d'informations peut avoir lieu à
un moment ou un autre quand vous
regardez comment fonctionne le domaine
de l'information vous voyez que des
grands acteurs d'information mondiaux et
quelquefois exceptionnellement bon petit
à petit
quand vous avez une plateforme comme
celle du new york times qui est un
nombre d'abonnés considérable eh bien
ils choisissent des sujets se disent sur
tel ou tel pays je vais devenir l'acteur
quasiment monopolistique de création sur
l'information de ce pays y compris
parfois aux dépens des fournisseurs
d'information locaux donc il faut pas
croire que les effets d'éviction qu'on
peut voir un moment donné sur les
créateurs de fiction où les créatures de
documentaires ne peut pas un jour où
l'autre avoir lieu en termes
d'information donc il ya mondialisation
du du marché et le deuxième point est le
troisième point évidemment c'est la
standardisation des offres qu'on voit
arriver alors même que la création comme
vous le savez c'est la prise de risque
c'est des premiers films cd première
oeuvre en ce qui concerne arte nous on
essaye et j'en termine par la d'avoir un
modèle j'allais dire européen en réseau
ont fait collaborer les gens ont fait
plus de premiers films que beaucoup ont
fait débuter des tas de personnes
d'autres débutent sur france télévisions
sur radio france dans l'univers du son
et je pense que la pluralité des acteurs
c'est ce qui permet à un moment donné à
la création de prendre tous ces risques
et où diverses visions en termes
d'information d'avoir lieu nous notre
information elle est binational parce
qu'elle est fait par une rédaction qui
parlent deux langues qui voit les choses
à travers le prisme de réalité et ça
donne une information différente de
celle de france télévisions et les deux
à mon avis sont nécessaires merci
monsieur le président
je suis le rapporteur
oui
bonjour
mesdames et messieurs les présidents
c'était absolument nécessaire que vous
soyez devant nous pour aborder ce sujet
crucial même si
quand on regarde notre sujet on pourrait
se dire mais ils sont pas directement
concernés étant du secteur public alors
pourquoi on a considéré cela important
parce que
cette reconfiguration du paysage
audiovisuel de façon assez accéléré ces
derniers temps a forcément au moins un
impact sur
un d'r le coeur aussi de l'audiovisuel
français avec des entreprises de service
public tout à fait performante qui ont
des parts de marché entre guillemets et
1 me dit ma tout à fait sérieux ou qui
dans
on marquait des points de façon très
importante ces dernières années là où
considéré qu' à l'époque qu'ils étaient
condamnés comme arte parce que on les
moquer sur le fait qu'ils étaient
passéiste élitiste
visible qu'en noir et blanc j'en passe
toutes les moqueries qui avait à une
époque est condamné à la mort certaine
ce type d'offre
en france et on a vu comment les choses
se sont retournés d'ailleurs c'était un
peu la même chose avec france inter et
radio france en général notamment france
culture on voit comment aussi des choses
son retour donc très important
est ce que la question je veux poser
à vous trois en ouverture c'est de nous
éclairer sur ce débat des concentrations
économiques et de leur impact sur
l'audiovisuel public d'autant que moi
personnellement à partir de mes propres
analyses bien entendu
je me suis dit
que
la fusion
tf1 m6 faisant apparaître dans hop c'est
largement commentée 75 ou approchant du
marché publicitaire captée par cette
entreprise
un audimat à plus de 40 % et à près de
75%
avant les informations c'est à dire au
moment où les français vont aller devant
l'écran pour s'informer ç'a un impact
non seulement sur la démocratie bien
entendu la pluralité mais en tous les
cas sur la concurrence avec le service
public est le principal concurrent
qui deviendrait le principal concurrent
et à mon grand étonnement et vous l'avez
répéter ici donc c'est une position
moins personnelle parce que je ne sais
pas si on peut faire de telles
déclarations non d'une entité
d'une otite et de service public vous
dites je suis favorable à la fusion tf1
m6
je ne sais pas si comme avis de droit
s'est demandé mais en tous les cas parce
que c'est à l'autorité de la concurrence
qu'on demande si elle est favorable et
si c'est possible ou alors à l'art comme
son avis vous avez tenu à le dire et le
répéter ici alors que tous les éléments
de base qu'on a en main dans celle là
que je demande des explications car je
connais votre votre pertinence dans vos
arguments général tout porte à croire
que c'est le service public qui va le
plus en pâtir notamment
par le marché publicitaire par la valeur
des droits et qui aura la main sur la
valeur des droits et des domaines encore
plus compliquée où déjà le service
public un grand retard et je sais que ça
vous émeut
la diffusion des sportives à
l'acquisition des droits ou on peut dire
que la de service public risque d'être
condamné à ne plus jamais dans la course
donc je suis très surpris d'une position
aussi affirmé certains me disent c'est
tactique parce que c'est une façon après
de demander plus aux services publics
pour qu'ils puissent résister
bon oui ce serait petit mont tactique si
c'était ça mais parce que je pense
effectivement qu'il faut renforcer le
service public et arrêter de baisser ses
dotations qu'il y ait ce rapprochement
passer vite aller on a vu votre utilité
notamment de la pandémie et des succès
d'audience la qualité des programmes qui
sont là et l'uil par ailleurs dans cette
forme et dans cette offre donc à vous
trois comment
vous voyez
deux choses la résistance de
l'audiovisuel français aux plateformes
parce que c'était évoqué comme argument
principal est ce que vous pensez que
c'est un moyen de résistance ou est ce
que vous vous dites
parce que vous avez mentionné des
chiffres et madame
est ici nous avons auditionné des
spécialistes notamment nathalie sonnac
qui nous a rappelés en termes de
concurrence capitalistique que là où
tout l'audiovisuel français et 5
milliards en cinq ans d'investissements
tout l'audiovisuel français en 55
milliards
apple tout seul c'est à dire son amazon
épique et s'est fait 15 milliards par an
est ce que ce type de rapprochement et
de nature à faire un peu peur ou un peu
bouger les cils aux grandes plate-formes
et est ce que parce que j'ai entendu
monsieur patino dans un colloque
dernièrement nous étions ensemble
dire que c'était aussi par l'agilité la
créativité la diversité de l'offre la
qualité que vous pouvez faire des
résultats notamment montrant les époques
les 5 millions de vues de la série
d'arte est qui concurrençait largement
ce que peut réaliser netfix parfois sont
bien contents quand ils font 5 millions
et la rareté on peut pas dire que c'est
le mastodonte de l'audiovisuel français
a pu le faire voilà ma question elle est
sur votre position par rapport en
général
aux concentrations à la façon de
résister quelle est la meilleure façon
de résister aux plateformes et après
deuxième question l'impact que vous
considérez corps à la fusion était aussi
sur le service public en général c'est
aux 3 suite d'une mutation à chacun de
vous croire mais ça sera dans un
deuxième temps
alors c'est effectivement je comprends
tout à fait monsieur le rat parcours
votre positionnement
je ne pense pas du tout que la fusion
tf1 m6 soit une manière de lutter contre
les plateformes je ne crois je ne pense
pas ça je pense que en fait on a un
marché des médias qui est composée
d'acteurs qui font de la télévision et
c'est un métier particulier dont on a ré
coûteux redécouvert les vertus au moment
du confinement s'est regardé ensemble en
fait la même chose ensemble vibrer
ensemble c'est se rassembler et puis des
offres qui sont d'ailleurs
complémentaires en réalité un plutôt d'
accès à une bibliothèque de contenus
dans une consommation très individuelle
de ces contenus pourquoi moi je pense
que c'est important qu'on ait des
acteurs télé en bonne santé en fait
c'est ça qui fait mon nom et je pense
que si tf1 m6 pense devoir fusionner
pour rester en bonne santé c'est
important qu'il le fasse parce qu'au
fond sur ce marché télévision nous
sommes pas très nombreux il ya nous le
service public et puis à quelques
groupes privés les plus importants sont
tf1 m6 et on a besoin d'avoir des
concurrents privés en bonne santé parce
que si demain je vous fais là contre à
poser si demain on avait des offres
privées qui se délitait ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui on a une excellente
offre privée également sur les des
offres privées qui se délite eh bien
c'est tout le média télé qui tomberait
et nous avec on doit défendre le média
télévision dans un monde où l'offre de
médias est beaucoup plus large que
simplement la télévision
néanmoins ça n'est pas sans caveat est
évidemment
et vous l'avez mentionné la question de
ne pas se faire ne pas avoir un
phénomène d'éviction comme le dit bruno
stoller des droits sportifs est
fondamentale donc là on s'en remet aussi
à mon sagesse de l'autorité de la
concurrence qui mettra des garde-fous et
il en faut il en faut sur les droits
sportifs notamment les grandes
compétitions qui sont comme celles que
je porte assez fièrement sur le sur la
poitrine léger jeux olympiques qui sont
de tout temps et les paralympiques qui
sont de tout temps sur france
télévisions roland garros voilà ça c'est
important aujourd'hui que france
télévisions arrive à garder ses droits
l'armée les seuls concurrents en la
matière ne sont pas tf1 m6 on voit les
grandes plateformes rentrer dans ce
marché là donc oui il ya des caves et
sur les droits sportifs il ya des
caviars sur la publicité vous avez
raison parce que le simple fait de
regrouper le marché publicitaire des
deux mastodontes que sont tf1 m6 et bien
fait baisser très spontanément le le
chiffre d'affaires publicitaire de
france télévisions il ya une prime il ya
une prime au leader on le sait n'est
donc ça ça a des conséquences je ne dis
pas qu'il faut je ne suis pas
naïve je ne pense pas qu'il faille bénir
n'importe quelle façon de fusionner tf1
m6 mais néanmoins je comprends ce besoin
d'avoir des acteurs nationaux qu'ils
soient puissants et qu'ils aient les
moyens de développer une offre qui qui
pèse par ailleurs je voudrais aussi
rappeler que en matière de création le
service public est très majoritaire si
on additionne ce que fait arte avec ce
que fait france télévisions en matière
de séries on doit avoir plus de 60% du
marché aujourd'hui là je ne suis pas sûr
que la fusion tf1 m6 et de grandes
grandes conséquences je n'en sais rien
mais ça c est à étudier mais
voilà le point en création de
des chaînes privées etc a nettement
moins important que celui qui a
aujourd'hui services publics dans
l'écosystème voilà pour pour cette
réponse rapide
j'ai reprendre le
le même propos que compte faire définir
nantes on a besoin d'avoir des
acteurs qu'ils soient aujourd'hui dans
un fonctionnement sain c'est beaucoup
plus vertueux pour nous d'être des
acteurs leaders sur un secteur en
croissance que tu es acteur leader sur
un secteur d croissance d'un secteur qui
s'appauvrirait parce que les acteurs
nationaux seraient en train de se
rabougrir sous l'effet de la concurrence
des grands acteurs internationaux et
c'est ça le risque aujourd'hui parce que
la diversité la qualité sans moyens
c'est d'ailleurs ça n'existe plus donc
il faut qu'on ait des acteurs qui sont
en capacité d'investir dans la diversité
dans la qualité des contenus et la
qualité aussi des plateformes
technologiques qui sont la porte d'accès
aujourd'hui vers les contenus pour nos
concitoyens or moi ce que je constate
c'est qu'aujourd'hui nos principaux
concurrents ce sont les acteurs du
streaming quand on veut par exemple le
talent je parlais de la musique c'est
une évidence aujourd'hui quand on veut
diffuser le concert qui lance l'album
d'un
du d'un acteur du secteur musical qui a
une certaine notoriété notre vrai
concurrent aujourd'hui c'est spotify
c'est ce que nous nous avons les droits
ou est-ce que c'est spotify qui les a
donc la concurrence a beaucoup changé y
compris pour nous on le voit aussi dans
les talents qui sont recherchées
aujourd'hui les talents en interne la
radio france qui sont recherchées à
l'extérieur ils sont recherchés par ces
plateformes qui veulent se lancer dans
la production de podcasts et qui font
appel à notre talent interne donc la
concurrence a vraiment changé de nature
et moi ce que je vois c'est que avec les
autres acteurs privés nous sommes
concurrents sur les contenus n'aura été
nous faisons face au même défi qui est
le risque et damman ça vaut tout
particulièrement pour le média radio le
risque de disruption c'est à dire du
fait que 1 les gamins s'interpose entre
nous et notre public en particulier dans
les voitures et sur les enceintes
connectés c'est que si dans les voitures
de demain sur le tableau de bord vous
voyez spotify et plus les médias radio
nous serons les premiers perdants c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous nous sommes
alliés avec les autres acteurs de la
radio pour créer une interface qui
s'appelle radio player donc on a des
intérêts communs qui sont objectifs qui
sont réelles et on a besoin pour sa
d'avoir des acteurs de la radio aussi
qu'il soit fort et c'est le sens de ce
que je vais essayer de développer tout à
l'heure
c'est beaucoup je n'ai pas rajouté
énormément de choses sauf peut-être pour
aller filer la métaphore ou plutôt la
comparaison avec ce qu'a dit sybille
vesle sur les voitures pour ce qui est
de delphine arnault fin de france
télévisions et arte nous l'enjeu il est
sûre les télécommandes c'est à dire il
peut nous arriver la même chose sur les
télécommandes que ce qui peut arriver à
sybille belle dans les voitures c'est à
dire que des accords particuliers qui
peuvent être passés entre constructeurs
et grandes plateformes mondiales qui ont
qui ont évidemment des forces de frappe
financière elles risquent elles font
déjà apparaître souvent le bouton
netflix elle risque arrive est d'arriver
à un moment donné où on aura d'abord des
boutons de plateformes comme un magasin
d'applications et puis la numérotation
sera à trouver de façon beaucoup plus
difficile donc on en revient à
l'économie de l'axé de la découvrabilité
qui est importante donc juste moi je
peux je suis assez enfin pas assez
d'ailleurs je suis totalement en écho de
ce qui vient d'être dit tf1 m6
moi j'ai pas pas à donner d'avis on voit
bien ce que ça peut donner en économies
d'échelle je suis pas je ne sais pas du
tout ce que ça peut donner en termes
d'effets de réseau ou de position par
rapport aux plateformes et c'est vrai
que pour un média comme arte
s'il ya des règles du jeu tels que les
ont définis tels que les a définis
delphine ernotte qui sont qui sont qui
sont là de façon à éviter les effets
d'éviction nous n'y voyons pas
véritablement de conséquences assez
lourdes aujourd'hui au jour le jour je
vais vous raconter la même histoire que
que les deux présidentes
de france télévisions et de radio france
si je regarde les talents c'est à dire
les salariés d' art et qui à un moment
donné ont quitté arte c'était entre
guillemets chasser comme on dit entre
guillemets par des plateformes en
l'occurrence américaine et non pas par
tf1 ou m6 ou un acteur du privé si je
regarde les concerts là aussi que nous
voulions avec lesquels nous avions des
accords ou les évictions ce sont les
mêmes
les luttes sur non pas seulement les
droits de fiction mais sur les liens
avec les auteurs les liens avec les
créateurs on voit bien que la cc cette
asymétrie là qui pèse vous vous me
pardonnerez c'est cette image que
j'utilise parfois on a parfois
l'impression d'être comment dire en
football le centre de formation et quand
on fait éclore un talent il va la
plupart du temps aujourd'hui
on a la crainte qu'il aille vers les
plateformes donc cette asymétrie là on
la vit chaque jour cette concurrence là
on l'avait chaque jour en revanche la
position concurrentielle de ce qui
serait un tf1 m6 se consolider ne nous
apparaît pas clairement une dernière
façon ou une dernière chose
n'imaginons pas non plus que si le
service public ne peut pas un moment
donné là je reviens sur ce qu avait dit
sur ce qu'on dit delphine ernotte et et
si bill weihl si nous ne pouvons pas
être présents nous aussi dans l' usage
de la plateforme isation des podcasts ou
autre
n'imaginons pas que c'est que que le
service public restera dans son rang
d'abord parce que les plateformes
petit à petit aujourd'hui on fait la
différence entre ce qui est linéaire est
ce qui est non linéaire on voit bien que
dans le domaine de la vidéo on ne voit
se développer chez les plateformes la
synchronicité les offre synchrone donc
ça a commencé par des possibilités
technologiques regarder ensemble a serré
qu'on a décidé d'attendre avec vous donc
c'est le c'est l'application partie
watching you hold chez netflix et puis
ça arrive très logiquement vers une
deuxième chose qui sont les grands
moments de synchronicité ou
synchronisation sociale que sont les
événements sportifs et donc ils ne vont
pas créer du live en permanence mais les
grands moments de synchronisation auront
lieu aussi sur les plateformes et donc
si on ne permet pas à un moment donné
aux services publics de rendre à la fois
par la régulation et 2 par j'allais dire
une capacité d'investissement
technologique de rentrer dans cet usage
là eh bien on va devenir seulement des
médias d'habitude pour un public
vieillissant or tous nos contenus les
gens que l'on découvre que l'on fait
travailler nous montre que si on ça
colle au bon usage on est parfaitement
reçus par les publics les plus jeunes et
moi j'insiste et je finis par là je peux
évidemment c'est il en serait de même
pour france télévisions et radio france
mais pour arte notre grande surprise ces
dernières années c'est d'être devenu un
média jeune vraiment chez les lycéens et
les collégiens pas seulement sur des
programmes un peu activiste est engagé
mais aussi sur des grandes séries
documentaires géopolitique sciences
historiques et ça c'est parce que on
colle à leur usage je vais pas je ne
vais pas vous mentir à 20h40 devant
l'écran depuis l'écran de télévision ils
ne sont pas là mais en revanche ils sont
là sur les chaînes youtube sur la
plateforme arte.tv donc il faut nous
laisser cette possibilité de faire
il fait présent une illustration
effectivement c'est un des vrais atouts
du service public aujourd'hui de rester
très innovant et de prendre des risques
sur des formats est sûr aussi des partis
pris technologique des risques sur les
formats je prends une illustration
jusqu'à présent il n'avait pas de radio
dédiée aux enfants pour la simple et
bonne raison qu'ils a pas de marché pour
ça la publicité la mesure
l'avenue danse de la radio se fait à
partir de 12 ans il n'y a pas de marché
publicitaire et donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle quand nous avons commencé
à lancer des podcasts pour enfin nous
avons été les premiers précurseur parce
que justement il n'y a pas de
rentabilité de modèle économique
et c'est cette capacité à innover à
créer une offre nouvelle vient du fait
que nous sommes un acteur qui répond
avant tout à un souci d'intérêt général
d'utilité avant un souci de rentabilité
et donc nous avons développé à partir de
2019 des podcasts pour enfants dont les
coûts de s'est fortement accru en 2020
évidemment poussé par les uns succession
de confinement et la demande des parents
d'avoir une alternative aux écrans avec
des contenus 100 % au lieu qu'ils soient
des contenus divertissants et
pédagogique intelligent ça répond à une
vraie demande il y avait une demande
très forte compte tenu de la forte
croissance de ces écoutes là qui dépasse
aujourd'hui quasiment des 50 millions d'
écoute depuis leur lancement donc c'est
un succès qui est absolument
considérable et qui montre qu'il y avait
un besoin qui n'étaient pas remplies et
notre capacité à innover justement nous
a permis d'aller vers ce segment la
wii donc si je résume un peu vous
regarder d'un oeil pas effrayer cette
possible fusion parce que
l'argument principal
même s'ils concernent moins radio france
mais quand même c'est que vous avez
besoin d'un secteur fort st
parce que
une baisse de l'audience de qualité un
déclin de ceux qui sont même vos
concurrents entraînerait tout le monde
dans le déclin si je résume
vous gardez de nous dire que de tf1 se
porte mal et m6 se porte mal pour
l'instant personne mire diagnostic sur
le fait que tf1 et m6 se portait mal y
en a qui se porte très mal qui vont se
porter encore beaucoup plus mal
d'ailleurs après ça
par contre là bon donc au gras et si
vous avez d'ailleurs des éléments mais
on lui demandera tf1 m6 de nous les
apporter sur leur santé économique etc
alors maintenant des questions à chacun
chacune
madame ernotte
vous avez été un peu mise malgré vous au
coeur d'une tempête
le 5 décembre 2017 lors d'une réunion
avec les députés de la république en
marché du modèle nom de la commission
des affaires culturelles et de
l'éducation
emmanuel macron et déclarait mais ça a
été filmé l'audiovisuel public c'est une
honte pour nos concitoyens c'est une
haute en terme de gouvernance c'est une
honte on ce que j'ai pu voir ces
dernières semaines de l'attitude des
dirigeants
en l'occurrence vous en étiez est ce que
vous avez à ce moment là considéré que
c'était une pression du pouvoir
politique on a parlé avec les autres
patrons de l'audiovisuel qu'on a
auditionné en tous les cas patron
d'euros des pressions possibles de
milieux économiques sur sûr
les médias là on sait très bien que vous
pouvez vous subir deux types de
pressions des pressions du pouvoir
politique auquel il ya avec lequel il ya
forcément un lien parce que les nommer
les processus de nomination
et ensuite la dépendance en terme de
négociation contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens et de budget alloué à
l'audiovisuel public chaque année est un
élément de lien indéniable d'ailleurs on
n'a pas enlevé
cette expression folle pour commencer
même à combattre cette idée qui est qu
on dit on dit le ministère de tutelle la
tutelle
on part de la tutelle pour l'audiovisuel
public quand on parle de l'état donc il
ya un lien
voilà indépendamment de la nature obligé
du lien par le financement
en général ce qui est demandé c'est pas
d'intervention et donc à ce moment là
est ce que vous avez vécu ça comme une
intervention une pression d'autant que
derrière il ya une renégociation très
forte
à la baisse de 2 du budget
vous étiez pas très favorable c'était de
notoriété publique et ensuite
sur le fait que quand il a fallu
accepter
ce soit sur des magazines à ce moment-là
d'investigation et d' enquête que
l'économie a été envisagée pouvez vous
me racontez ce moment comment vous
l'avez vécu pression par pression est en
général quel est votre regard sur les
pressions du pouvoir politique en place
monsieur le rapporteur je vais répondre
beaucoup plus largement en fait j'ai
prêté serment donc je pense que c'est
très important ce que je vais vous dire
et je suis très affirmative
ça fait six ans et demi que je suis
président de france télévisions est ce
que j'ai subi un quelconque moment une
pression pour ne pas diffuser ou pour
intervenir sur une ligne éditoriale
quelconque que ce soit du précédent
gouvernement sous la présidence de
françois hollande ou l'actuel
gouvernement sous la présidence d
manueel macron la réponse est non
non
et j'estime qu'on a énormément de chance
en france parce que effectivement nous
avons un audiovisuel public libre et
indépendant et je vous renvoie à la
programmation de nos magazines
d'investigation
monsieur le rapporteur vous me direz si
vous estimez qu'il sont
particulièrement d'un côté ou
particulièrement de l'autre je peux vous
dire que moi je veille à ce que
la rédaction les rédactions puisqu'il y
aller la rédaction nationale les
rédactions en région et outre mer
puissent travailler en toute
indépendance
alors oui on a réduit les budgets de
quelques on a beaucoup baissé les
effectifs à france télévisions en disant
on aura baisser les effectifs de 20%
alors oui l'information a été concernée
et oui ça a pu être un peu utilisé ce
présupposé de pression politique pour
défendre un budget un peu à la baisse
oui ça a été utilisée est ce que pour
autant
l'investigation se porte mal au sein du
service public non elle se porte
extrêmement bien les identifier là des
cases
qui sont qui sont bien présentes qui
progressent d'ailleurs donc voilà donc à
la réponse est ce que vous vous sentez
vous êtes senti en six ans et demi un
donc longue expérience quand même un
quelconque même moment sous pression
politique je le redis ici la réponse est
non et alors leleu deuxième type de
pression que d'ailleurs on ya évoqué à
travers d'autres auditions ces
dépressions au lieu de puissance
économique sur la publicité notamment le
chantage à la publicité vous savez
notamment cette affaire où vincent
bolloré a demandé 50 millions à france
télévisions pour avoir diffusé un
documentaire qui ne lui plaisait pas et
finalement les jugements on condamnait
vincent bolloré lui même a donné dix
mille euros pour procédure abusive
est ce que vous pouvez
pouvez-nous dire ça a bien existé ce
type de pression y compris sur en termes
de 2,2
comment dire d'une procédure bâillon
pour faire peur et empêcher de
travailler sur certains sujets parce que
les risques encourus ensuite en justice
peuvent être dramatiques pour le
diffuseur ou le producteur ou alors
d'autres pressions qui sont sur le
marché publicitaire c'est à dire de ne
plus vous donnez de publicité si vous
faites ceci ou cela est ce que vous avez
vécu ça dans votre dans votre mandat
est-ce que j'étais en effet convoqué au
tribunal pour avoir diffusé un
documentaire un reportage pardon qui ne
convenait pas à certaines personnes oui
j'ai plus monsieur assouline j'ai plus
de 30 mise en examen pour diffamation
etc mais je dirais c'est mon rôle et
est-ce que ça m'empêche de diffuser ou
est-ce que ça m'empêche de continuer à
travailler d'aucune manière c'est le
sais vous allez on les directeurs de
publication ont tous l'habitude de ça
c'est vrai dans la presse c'est vrai à
la télévision c'est vrai à la radio on
connaît ces méthodes là est ce que ça
nous influence nous ont scellé on est
suffisamment solide sur nos missions
confortés dans notre rôle auprès de nos
concitoyens pour ne pas bouger d'un iota
dans ces cas là donc bien sûr qu'il y en
a toujours des pressions est ce que pour
autant je me sens difficultés pour
garantir l'indépendance du service
public vis-à-vis des pouvoirs privé la
réponse est non je ne me sens pas en
difficulté
mes collègues vont poser d'autres
questions ou voit revenir là dessus
parce que ma question n'est pas si vous
cédez mais si vous souvenez de moments
où on a supprimé des de la publicité
pour faire pression sur vous je ne sais
pas vous qui est en question c'est je
vous demande de nous raconter
quel type de pression que vous subissez
notamment si une de ce type aient lieu
donc voilà si vous pouvez nous répondre
plus tard dont l'audition ça c'était ça
ma question concrète est ce que vous
savez vous-même à ces pressions
madame veil
vous avez
souvent dans le service public est
attaqué comme çà a été rappelé de façon
publique de façon unie beaucoup plus
forte que incertain une certaine époque
moi je sais très bien par exemple ce que
je subis et j'aimerais avoir votre votre
réflexion là dessus
quand j'additionne
le directeur de la rédaction de ces news
ou monsieur bolloré ce qui inondent mon
compte twitter de troll par centaines
c'est vous ne seriez pas
demandé aux services publics ou à radio
france
ce que vous demander monsieur vincent
bolloré alors qu'ils sont une officine
de la gauche
ou d'idées très marqué en gros vous avez
été mis en accusation sur le pluralisme
et sur la nature même du côté pluraliste
de vote radio bien entendu je ne partage
pas ces propos mais je veux vous
demander de nous le dire le plus
précisément possible
comment s'organise le pluralisme et la
diversité sur le service public
peut-être pour
rappeler quelques vérités ne pas être
dans un débat disons les faits sont sont
malmenés au profit juste de deux
volontés de discrédit d'oxydé qu'est ce
que vous nous répondez à cette
accusation et comment voulez payer
comment s'organise le pluralisme
diversité
d'une radio qui est la première radio de
france aujourd'hui il faut le rappeler
est probablement parce qu'elle plaît
parce que elle a trouvé un public
important
sur cette question sur laquelle je
je me suis prononcé dans une tribune
dans le figaro il ya quelques mois parce
qu'effectivement nous avions
de manière récurrente astrid et que vous
n'aidez t'exprimer qui étaient exprimées
et je pense que ce n'est pas du tout le
rôle du service public de rentrer dans
la mêlée mais de donner la preuve en
revanche des du respect du principe de
pluralisme strictes qui est respectée
sur nos antennes de la qualité aussi des
contenus qui permettent de ne pas
contribuer à dégrader le débat
publiquement au contraire à l'enrichir
et faire qu'ils se portent bien
et ça repose sur des règles internes et
une culture d'entreprise très ancienne
nous avons installé nombre de codes de
principe relatives à l'information
qui sont respectées par toutes nos
chaînes on en a fait approuver un par
l'ensemble de nos rédactions il ya deux
ans dans le contexte justement où de
plus en plus les questions
du rôle de nos rédactions sont
mises en avant on a
également ajouté à ce dispositif phare
guide des bonnes pratiques à l'usagé des
réseaux sociaux qui permet aussi
de définir des règles qui protègent nos
journalistes contre ce que vous décrivez
c'est à dire des attaques qui vont aussi
bien dans un sens que dans un autre et
la meilleure preuve que quelque part
nous sommes sur une ligne d'équilibré
elin qui rassemble aussi le plus grand
nombre de français c'est que non
seulement nous aujourd'hui on surmonte
donc ça veut dire que nous restons pas
sur simplement une position qui serait
une position qui ne conviendra qu'à une
partie des français mais surtout que
on le fait dans des conditions où
on sait participer le plus possible à la
qualité du débat public je veux dire
qu'en tant que présente de radio france
ma première mission c'est de préserver
l'indépendance de mes rédactions contre
toute tentative d'influencé extérieure
et je rejoins les propos définir note
pour dire que
j'ai pu voir depuis que je suis à la
tête de radio france à quel point cette
indépendance des médias publics est
rentré dans les esprits aujourd'hui de
tous les responsables politiques parce
que jamais à aucun moment je n'ai eu à
faire face à une quelconque tentative d'
influence à aucun moment malgré
les soupçons qui peuvent parfois être
rappelés et dont certaines des remarques
que vous évoquez auquel elle peut faire
écho je n'ai jamais eu à faire face à
une quelconque tentative influence donc
cette indépendance est réelle elle est
ancrée dans les rédactions et elle se
manifeste par le pluralisme et la très
grande diversité des opinions qui sont
représentés je pense que les critiques
auxquelles on fait face aujourd'hui et
que vous décrivez et qui sont
le reflet d'une violence extrême sur les
réseaux sociaux tiennent justement en
fonctionnement de ces réseaux que bruno
patino a très bien décrit dans deux
ouvrages que nous connaissons tous qui
font référence aujourd'hui à savoir le
fait que nous sommes enfermés dans des
bulles cognitive et que nous n'avons
plus l'habitude d'être confrontés à
l'altérité et que justement le rôle du
service public c'est de mener le débat
le plus large pour faire se confronter
des points de vue différents c'est ça
aussi qui suscite la la
a parfois la compréhension possible et
le fait qu'on ait autant de messages qui
critiquent le fait qu on soutiendra le
gouvernement que de messages qui disent
que on est au contraire en soutien
plutôt de tel ou tel type id ou tel
autre monde que on arrive à une ligne
d'équilibré général qui nous permet
d'essayer de rats de participer aux
débats de la minière la plus large la
plus ouverte en respectant toujours le
principe de la liberté d'expression et
de la pluralité aussi des opinions et
des points de vue donc c'est ça qui est
le coeur de notre travail et je pense
que c'est ça aussi qui explique les
succès de nos antennes et qui nous
permet de fédérer de la manière la plus
large possible
michel logis
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs
depuis le début de deux nos auditions
pas de session d'aujourd'hui ont
constaté ce sera encore aujourd'hui que
le monde des médias est en pleine
évolution les usages aussi vous avez
parlé il doit s'adapter il serait que
les probiotiques sont multiples lorsque
on doit être la tête de tous ces médias
c'est premièrement la capacité investir
et vous l'avez dit sylvie weil à
plusieurs reprises et surtout vers
l'innovation
il ya aussi le problème de la publicité
parce que même si c'est moins évident
sur les chaînes publiques la publicité
reste quand même un élément essentiel et
de souci vous l'avez signalé ce sont les
abonnements pour tout ce qui est payant
et puis la question de l'indépendance
des rédactions est toujours là vous
venez de vous exprimer mais je lui
demandais quelque chose d'un peu petit
peu plus précis la concurrence c'est
très bien la concurrence entre les
grands groupes la concurrence avec les
grandes plates formes internationales
mais
finalement on parle de beaucoup de
choses et on oublie la cible la cible
cas même si le public
c'est le public est une radio il doit
être écouté une télévision doit être vu
un journal doit être lu je pense que ce
qui fait la différence ensuite bien ce
sont les auditeurs les téléspectateurs
et les lecteurs et d'ailleurs vous le
prouver vous le prouver on parle de
grands groupes qui détiennent de
nombreux médias et quand on voit les
audiences
voit que c'est loin des résultats qu'ils
avaient espéré dans un premier temps
donc on vient quand même beaucoup de
moyens on n'atteint pas forcément
sensible si on ne vise pas un public
alors juste deux précisions dans mes
questions la première question on a
parlé donc des de la constitution
actuelle et à venir de grands groupes
est ce que pour vous c'est inéluctable
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui va
apporter
un plus à l'audiovisuel public français
ou est-ce que vous pensez que on va se
retrouver finalement tout petit par
rapport aux autres si jamais on ne va
pas vers cette cible à la deuxième
question c'est toujours sur
l'indépendance des journalistes
sous les arbres quel regard vous avez
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est dans
les services publics que l'indépendance
des journalistes et le mieux maîtrisé et
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
aussi parce que c'est bien beau d'avoir
une indépendance mais sur quels critères
sont recrutés les journalistes merci
réponse
oui
première question portant sur
au pardon je suis pas sûr d'avoir
compris sur audience versus ah oui
qu'est-ce que ça va oui voilà oui alors
moi je voulais vous répondre en vous
disant qu'en fait on est comme souvent
dans l'audiovisuel d'ailleurs en france
très très concentré sur les acteurs
français mais ce qu'on vous dit depuis
le début c'est que notre problème c'est
pas les acteurs français en fait c'est
les quasi monopoles et oligopoles
america donc on peut disserter sur le
fait qu'il faudrait un plus ou moins
d'acteurs en france mais notre sujet
c'est qu'on a besoin de s'armer face à
ces zones igo paul américain et
peut-être demain d'autres nationalités
c'est ça notre sujet principal est ce
que la fusion tf1 m6 va aider dans
l'agencé rien en fait c'est pas ça pour
moi c'est pas c'est pas sont sans doute
le plus important le plus important pour
lutter contre ces
acteurs là c'est d'appuyer sur ce qu'il
fait sur ce qui fonde nos forces et
quelles sont nos forces qui sont
difficiles à reproduire
d'abord il ya l'information parce que
l'information elle se fait pas depuis la
côte ouest on peut dire ce qu'on veut
mais il faut des équipes des
journalistes qui sont sur le terrain
donc ça et d'ailleurs ces centrales dans
les offres de service public c'est
absolument déterminant deuxièmement et
donc pour répondre à la question des
journalistes on travaille avec les
écoles de journalisme en france on
s'ouvre d'ailleurs on essaie de recruter
dans tous les milieux sociaux parce que
ça fait partie aussi de nos missions de
service public que d'avoir au sein de
nos rédactions la représentation de la
société française dans l'ensemble donc
rien que de très traditionnel on passe
par les écoles de journalisme en france
donc l'information bien sûr ces
centrales tout ce qui touche à la
proximité ce qui requiert de la présence
sur place et pas que l'information c'est
ce que nous avons mis en chantier avec
ma collègue sybille veille sur l'offre
numérique de proximité là qui va faire
ça sur la culture
parce que pardon mais qui peut être
aussi pertinent que nous le sommes sur
l'exposition de spectacle vivant
bruno en parlerait fort bien mais qui a
fait culturebox cependant le confinement
qui a fait culture prix mais c'est une
oeuvre commune pour rendre accessible la
culture sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est nous donc c'est ce sont nos
spécificités et qui investit dans la
création française
c'est encore massivement de service
public donc c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
qu'on s'appuie est évidemment faire
évoluer la façon dont on parle on
converse avec nos publics le temps où on
mettait un honneur et on attendait que
ça se passe est révolu on sait que
maintenant il faut être en conversation
avec nos publics d'ailleurs si vous
regardez sur le l'application de france
info vous verrez que tout le monde peut
nous poser une question et un
journaliste qui va répondre cette
conversation elle est très importante et
aussi être capable comme le disait très
justement vous nous de faire découvrir
c'est à dire d'avoir à la fois cette
relation avec tous et en même temps une
relation particulière avec chacun
ça c'est de la technologie en effet
c'est de l'investissement technologique
c'est aussi une forme de savoir faire
qu'on a qu'on acquiert et qui est
absolument nécessaire et pour lesquelles
on est de manière générale en france
comme en europe pas en avance par
rapport aux acteurs américains c'est
vrai dans l'audiovisuel comme c'est vrai
dans d'autres secteurs regardez amazon
versus le reste du monde
juste en complément de ce qui vient
d'être dit je pense que non pardon on
est tous focalisés sur la taille alors
que ce qu'on vit c'est l'étendue c'est à
dire l'important ce n'est pas d'être
gros petit c'est de savoir si vous vous
êtes mondiale locales ou multi local si
j'ose dire et je pense que c'est là où
se structurent le marché qui arrive et
donc je crois pas du tout que on va se
confronter un modèle où il y aura que
des géants
mais le lac et le questionnement c'est
de savoir s'il ya encore une place pour
des modèles qui sont uniquement locaux
uniquement nationaux mais qui peuvent
être petit vous pouvez être tout à fait
petit et mondiale paradoxalement ou
énorme et national ce que je veux dire
que là je crois que les frontières
vraiment cessé sur l'étendue new art et
on essaie d'être européen ça veut pas
dire qu'on essaye d'être gros
souvent on me dit ça c'est moi j'ai
jamais dit on va faire le nez de flics
européen je suis pas
je suis encore raisonnable en tout cas
je le crois mais je pense qu'on peut
être européen c'est à dire que notre
étendue elle peut être européenne on
allait droit européen etc mais je ne
pense pas que nous allons être gros mais
je pense qu'on peut être pertinent et
donc il ya des marchés aujourd'hui on
peut être pertinent sans pour autant
être gros mais la question c'est
effectivement de bien déterminer quelle
est l'étendue géographique qui est
sienne aujourd'hui on est tous j'allais
dire aveuglé par la taille des acteurs
mondiaux parce qu'ils sont énormes et
mondiaux on voit poindre maintenant des
acteurs qui sont mondiaux mais pas
forcément grand la réponse à un acteur
mondial et grand n'est pas forcément un
acteur national énorme
il se peut qu'il y en ait mais on voit
bien que le marché va être à la fois sur
la pertinence et et sur la taille mais
encore une fois je pense que il faut
vraiment avoir ça en tête c'est à dire
le questionnement ce qu'on essaye aussi
tous de défendre c'est le fait qu' il
peut y avoir des offres quand même
qu'ils soient de proximité que cette
proximité soient locales qu'elles soient
nationales ou qu'elles soient européens
sur l'autre question qui portait sur
l'indépendance moi je
suis convaincu que l'indépendance repose
à la fois sur une culture d'entreprise
qui repose sur les principes
d'organisation du travail des rédactions
et sur des principes structurelles dans
le service public ça repose notamment
sur le mode de nomination des présidents
qu'il faut intervenir une autorité
administrative indépendante et ça repose
aussi sur le mode de financement
le fait d'avoir une taxe qui soit une
taxe affectée au financement de
l'audiovisuel public est aussi une
garantie de financement parce que la
manière dont on est financé et le
dialogue qu'on a et qui passent par
l'intermédiaire du législateur pour
arrêtez ce qui constitue nos moyens est
un élément aussi de notre indépendance
est d'ailleurs par rapport à la question
selon le rapporteur pose est ce n'est
pas anodin qu'il y ait autant de
critiques qu'ils soient se soit
développée ces derniers mois de manière
très démagogiques à un moment donné où
la question du financement de
l'audiovisuel public va être posée il ne
faut pas être dupe en tout cas on n'est
absolument pas dupe sur le fait que ces
critiques d'ailleurs on ôte augmenter à
mesure que nos audiences progressait
aussi donc c'est c'est quelque chose qui
est évidemment
là ne faut pas être regardé
pour ce que pour ce qu'il signifie enfin
je dirais de manière assez nette à la
critique qui peut être fait par certains
qui peut croire qu'un groupe de radio
qui est réunie chaque jour 15 millions
et demi d'auditeurs réunissent des gens
qui pensent tous dans le même sens et la
même chose donc oui nous sommes un
groupe qui rassemble un nombre très
important de français au fur et à mesure
de
voilà ses succès on voit bien que les
critiques aussi se sont développés
et ont été repris dans un dans le cadre
là de deux débats politiques qui précède
qui ont précédé démarrage la campagne
présidentielle et qui ont
instrumentalisé beaucoup la question de
l'audiovisuel public
on va poursuivre jusqu'à 17h15 donc on a
un peu encore un peu de temps mais je
vais vous demander quand même d'être
bref dans vos questions pour que l'on
puisse
puis c'est d'abord tous les poser sylvie
robert
oui merci mais c'est le président alors
j'essaie dé de brèves il ya beaucoup de
questions qui ont déjà été posées
d'abord - je voudrais vous remercier mes
dames et et monsieur pour vos propos je
suis intimement persuadé que service
public forte gage d'une vitalité
démocratique et ça c'est absolument
important à à préserver vous avez parlé
de qualité de l'information
je trouve que dans une commission
denquête comme la nôtre on se doit de
parler de la qualité de l'information
où on n'est plus dans le commentaire
aujourd'hui mais quand vous parlez de
effectivement de journalisme
d'investigation
je pense que c'est extrêmement important
parce que tout part de là et je crois
que c'est aussi la qualité d'un service
public est vraiment pour cela je
voudrais vous en remercier parce que
derrière il ya un autre mot que vous
avez prononcé l'un de vous c'est la
confiance je crois aussi que c'est une
question démocratique et que tout ça
démocratie confiance qualité de
l'information sont pour moi en tout cas
des conditions à réunir pour
continuer à en tout cas garantir ce
service public alors je vais essayer de
pousser un petit peu plus loin c'était
très intéressé par vos propos mal
amerloques parce que je m'interrogeais
comme rapporteur sur le fait que vous
ayez dit que finalement la fusion m6 tf1
n'était pas un problème en soi je résume
d'abord ça n'était pas pour contrer les
plateformes mais c'était finalement une
forme de
d'émulation a créé dans notre pays pour
que parce qu'il ya un service de
l'audiovisuel et les finalement le fait
de cette concentration ne pourrait ne
pourrait ne pas être un problème pour le
service public est ce que vous pensez
cependant que les conditions sont
réunies pour que cette émulation existe
vraiment alors je vais pas revenir sur
la question du financement
mais j'étais très intéressé parce que
c'est une dimension qu'on a peu abordés
dans cette commission denquête vous avez
beaucoup parlé de questions de
l'innovation de technologie
d'anticipation sur les usages et ça je
pense que cette question de souveraineté
technologique
dans l'innovation est un est un point
important et je voudrais savoir
dans les conditions à réunir pour que
cette émulation si ça existe existe
vraiment si c'est une de vos priorités
ou s'il y en a d'autres on a en d'autres
termes est-ce que dans vos priorités en
termes de stratégie pour que vous
puissiez être en capacité
voilà d'être dans un paysage dans un
écosystème qui soit véritablement on va
dire
dynamique si cette concentration existe
est ce que pour vous cette priorité est
lié aux questions d'innovation et de
technologie ou est ce que c'est une
question de financement ou autre je vous
demande pas de dire il faut j'ai compris
en mai je me pose cette question
parce que je suis comme vous persuadé
que ça ne ça n'a pas beaucoup d'effet
pour contrer les grandes les grandes
plateformes et puis enfin ma deuxième
question j'ai écouté monsieur patino
c'est aussi très intéressant parce que
vous venez de dire l'importance et
l'étendue et non pas le alors est ce que
ça voudrait dire que
là qui sont la proximité la question de
de l'organisation même de notre paysage
pourrait plus se fonder sur
une diversité c'est un mot que vous
n'avez pas beaucoup employé j'ai entendu
informations proximité culture moi je le
mets je mets le mot diversité et que
finalement dans le paysage - joue aussi
en bretagne à une télé locale qui est
très et voilà en tout cas dynamique
qu'il ya des rapprochements france 3 est
ce que ces versets modèle-là peut-être
alors là je plus de déconcentration
aussi plus de 2 alors les länder son
travail différemment mais dans notre
pays est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer une
forme de gouvernance beaucoup plus
déconcentré beaucoup plus proche des
citoyens et je m'arrête là mais ce
président ça aussi je pense que dans
leur la relation aux citoyens ce sont
des orientations et des dimensions qu'il
faut prendre en compte est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec cela merci
pour pour répondre à votre question oui
vous avez raison dans
notre monde
de transformation digitale l'innovation
et la techno sont assez central parce
que d'abord la révolution technologique
n'est pas fini on voit par exemple ce
qui est en train de se passer sur le
métavers c'est à dire le passage en
trois dimensions de l'internet le fait
de vivre quasiment de ressentir un
nouvel univers le fait que que des
géants de la tech investissent des
milliards dans ces nouvelles
technologies
je pense que là sur ce champ mon opinion
c'est qu'on a on a raté l'internet 2d
donc il faudrait essayer peut-être de
prendre pied sur l'internet 3d donc ça
c'est un champ nouveau dans lequel
d'ailleurs en france on a un certain
nombre de compétences typiquement on a
beaucoup de on a des grandes compétences
en jeu vidéo on a des grandes
compétences son animation
voilà donc donc il ya peut-être matière
là
au delà de l'innovation technologique
dont on a besoin dans notre relation
avec avec nous nos concitoyens nos
téléspectateurs il ya tout un champ de
prospective que nous que nous menons
d'ailleurs parce que l'innovation ne
s'arrête pas là où nous en sommes
aujourd'hui donc ce champ là il est très
très important et je fais le lien quand
même avec le financement parce que
l'innovation c'est de l'investissement
en réalité donc ça demande des moyens
que pour pouvoir justement investir
parfois on investit sur un champ et on
se rend compte qu'il débouche pas
vraiment sur quelque chose c'est presque
un peu parfois expérimental pas toujours
heureusement mais oui et puis il ya la
5g qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'elle est
quelle est la place de la
des contenus de l'audiovisuel public
dans la 5g de m'en ont parlé sur les
voitures on sait que ça peut permettre
de mettre des voitures en communication
permanente
donc voilà quelle est notre place dans
ce dans ce nouvel écosystème ça c'est
des questions qui restent ouvertes et
qui sont assez fondamental je suis
d'accord avec vous sur la question des
médias locaux et d'une plus forte des
concentrations c'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire en réalité
on adorerait pousser jusqu'à
l'organisation des allemands mais je
vous rappelle que pour ce faire la
notation est deux fois plus importante
en allemagne qu'il ne l'est en france je
suis pas sûr qu'on a envie de revenir à
des chaînes totalement locale en réalité
mais néanmoins et on s'est lancé avec
france 3 dans une régionalisation assez
forte qui qui se traduit par des
programmes beaucoup plus ancrée
localement des retransmissions sportives
des retransmissions d'événements
culturels une place de l'information qui
s'est accrue autour des gros carrefours
très très fort en audience les matinales
commune avec radio france voilà tout un
champ de ré l'ancrage dans au plus près
des gens
pour les chaînes de la télévision et
nous avons un projet sur lequel nous
travaillons ardemment avec sybil est de
faire un numérique ou là on est
complètement orientée autour des
autour des zones de vie des gens parce
que le local ne correspond ni allah ni
au département ni même parfois la
municipalité quand elle est très très
grande ça peut être le quartier vraiment
ce que les gens considèrent comme étant
leur zone de vie là où ils circulent les
grâce au numérique qui au fait qu'on
peut
automatiquement aller chercher les
contenus qui concerne une zone de vie
donné on va essayer de proposer un
numérique très très innovant où
justement on va se concentrer autour de
l' eau des zones vip ce qu'on peut en
avoir plusieurs à voir le lieu où on est
et où on a encore des attaches
familiales et puis le lieu où on vit qui
est différent et et est donc on
travaille ardemment à cette question de
la proximité parce qu'on voit que c'est
un vrai une vraie attendre les gens en
fait qui est en train plutôt en train
d'augmenter + le monde devient complexe
qu on a envie aussi de se ré ancrés
localement d'avoir ses repères proche de
chez soi donc là dessus je pense qu'on a
un vrai avantage compétitif et
concurrentiel
on entend bien mettre à profit pour pour
mieux servir nos nos concitoyens
pour juste pour que sur le début de
votre propos je pense je pense que
fondamentalement le rôle du service
public outre le fait de
fédérer très largement par départ ces
contenus
n'ont pas de faire des choses
différentes des acteurs privés mais de
les faire différemment son rôle c'est
aussi d'avoir un effet d'entraînement
positifs sur le secteur dans lequel nous
intervenons et je pense que c'est
vraiment ce que l'on essaie de faire
dans le secteur de la radio et de
l'audio on s'est battu pour que le
dernier + puis s'est développé en france
on
on essaie aussi sur tout ce qui est
droit d'auteur droits voisins d'avoir
une action qui soit aussi une action un
peu
précurseur en concluant des accords avec
les organismes de gestion de droits en
faisant en sorte que le respect de ces
accords soient des conditions à la
reprise nos contenus par les plateformes
qui va les distribuer de que ça fait
partie des missions du service public
d'avoir un effet positif et entraînant
sur son secteur et c'est vraiment ce à
quoi voilà on s'efforce alors on
s'efforce d'être à la hauteur aussi de
cette mission là qui est une est un rôle
aussi d'entraînement pour le secteur
dans son ensemble
j'aurais voulu donner
merci président
avec la concentration on a là le mot
phare de la thématique de cette
commission que je rappelle quand même
mettre en lumière les processus ayant
permis pouvant aboutir à une
concentration dans les médias en france
et d'évaluer l'impact de cette
concentration dans une démocratie
donc la concentration c'est un phénomène
vieux comme le monde je vais pas remonté
à robert hersant
olivier de serge dassault pardon
voilà donc c'est un petit peu un serpent
de mer que nous avons et au moins sur
les deux questions qui sont là en tout
cas les les deux axes vous avez
quasiment à l'unisson répondu pour le
premier et s'attend à créditer
d'ailleurs ce que disait monsieur eveno
grand spécialiste du sujet il ya pas si
longtemps historien des médias et à
savoir que si je dois résumé la
concentration a plus à voir avec
l'économique et le pluralisme lui avec
la démocratie
et par rapport à sagy il ya quelque
chose juste avant les deux questions qui
sont très rapides monsieur le président
il ya quelque chose d'assez salutaire
d'entendre des responsables du service
public employer les mots effectivement
de pluralisme
de qualité de performance de résistance
aux plateformes et d'innovation le tout
au service d'une diversité culturelle ça
ça nous va bien et je pense tous autant
que nous sommes autour de cette table
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de dire que au
passage nous sommes tous tributaires de
quelque chose qui manque cruellement
c'est à dire une réforme de
l'audiovisuel
puisque nous sommes toujours en attente
et nous sommes toujours avec une loi de
86 vieille comme le monde et qui sommes
qui sont un petit peu le formol et à la
veille de la disparition de la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public qui
vous intéresse et nous aussi sans qu'on
sache d'ailleurs sauf quelques aimable
bricolage ce que deviendra demain les
ressources du service public alors vous
avez dit tout à l'heure madame ernotte
quelque chose également d'intéressants
qui est que nous avons une presse
d'opinion en france
elle a même financé c'est à dire que les
contribuables que nous sommes financent
une presse d'opinion y compris pour une
opinion qui n'est pas forcément dans sa
sensibilité
nous l'acceptons encore parce que c'est
un fondement légal et il est vieux lui
aussi comme le monde en revanche tout à
l'heure et je tiens à préciser le
la comparaison pour l'audiovisuel c'est
totalement différent
on considère les fréquences comme étant
un bien public c'est les raisons pour
lesquelles on attribue ces fréquences et
que l'on a donc pas un autre duo visuel
d'opinion il ne devient par la force des
choses et même si les lois les cahiers
des charges et autres
on est très habile pour écrire dans
notre pays mais le résultat c'est ce que
l'on voit c'est à dire sans être taquin
ce que d'aucuns ont écrit dans des
magazines connu que y compris le service
public était orienté politiquement
encore une fois ce n'est pas moi qui
parle c'est
ce qui ressort d'un article
particulièrement sérieux et de gens que
l'on croise parce qu'on vit tous dans la
vraie vie et on croise des gens qui
pensent que le service public sans être
sous la tutelle du président de la
république bien sûr mais le fait et
c'était la question de mon collègue
michel laugier et amis dans le
recrutement même des journalistes qui
sont dans les antennes 6e sont orientés
ce n'est pas leur hiérarchie qui va
aller leur chercher des poux dans la
tête
tout ça pour dire que
le les médias d'opinion par la force des
choses et puisque tout le monde pense à
6 news
existe qu'on le veuille ou non
alors où on veut les combattre ce qui
sera un combat d'arrière-garde parce
qu'encore une fois c'est quelque chose
qui existera quoi qu'il en soit parce
que ça le devient voilà
est-ce qu'il ne convient pas à ce moment
là de dire ouvertement
parce que personne ne force personne n'y
a pas la milice qui passe en rempart
cadres dans la rue pour dire vous allez
regarder ses news vous allez regarder
france info vous allez regarder
tartempion personne ne force
l'offre est sur la table comme des
journaux voilà je vais je vais terminer
petit peu un voilà donc à partir de là
est ce que vous pensez que le temps
n'est pas venu de déboucher sur un
audiovisuel d'opinion qui réglerait au
moins une partie du g le tout dans la
pluralité et bien évidemment parce que
quel que soit les sensibilités
politiques il y assez de personnes
fortunées
l'histoire de notre pays l'a bien prouvé
aussi pour financer qui est un média
plutôt de sensibilité vous m'avez
compris la deuxième et dernière question
vous avez parlé d'europe chacun à votre
façon
et je vous sais particulièrement
attentif au sujet et pour cause et je
voulais savoir madame r note en tant que
présidente depuis le 1er janvier 2021 de
l'ue er
comment vous perceviez ça et comment
vous perceviez justement ce pluralisme
et ce respect du pluralisme à l'aune de
l'europe et comment l'europe pourrait
peut-être intervenir ou pas et si ça
serait le bienvenu y compris dans
d'autres pays
dans cette différence entre pluralisme
et démocratie
j'ajoute pour finir que ce qu'a dit
monsieur patino il l'avait dit déjà lors
de son audition pour le projet de loi de
finances me paraît crucial
entre des réseaux et l'échelle et sur
les petits qui sont sur des marchés très
précis sur des savoir-faire très précis
de très haute qualité et qui eux quoi
qu'ils se passent s'en sortiront
toujours
et puis puisque c'est une vous avez
employé à l'heure à dessein peut-être je
ne sais pas mais la métaphore des
centres de formation de football c'est
exactement c'est exactement le même
processus et dieu sait si ça nous tient
en haleine en ce moment
oui je vais répondre à la question
directe de monsieur le sénateur hugonnet
sur le r et comment on voit cette
question du pluralisme
ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est que
j'ai le sentiment que la commission
européenne
n'est plus du tout naïve dans cette
guerre médiatique entre géants de la
tech et médias nationaux donc ça c'est
déjà un point extrêmement positif il ya
deux actes qui nous concerne pas
uniquement nous en tant que média mais
qui sont absolument essentielles non un
qui a été votée au parlement il me
semble dans les dents les jours que kim
qui viennent de s'écouler le digital
services act et qui essaie d'établir au
fond en ligne les mêmes règles que ce
qu'on applique dans la vie et dans la
vie réelle pour lutter contre la
désinformation la haine en ligne etc et
le dma pour essayer de
trouver un de faire que la place de
marché sur internet soit plus équilibré
et ne profite pas qu'aux aux énormes
mastodontes et laisse une place aux plus
petits acteurs locaux sur la question du
pluralisme
est là pour l'instant rien n'est encore
sur la table mais j'ai entendu parler
parle par le comice à breton notamment
du media freedom act qui viserait
justement à
poser un texte comment sur l'impératif
de la liberté d'expression du pluralisme
qui est une des composantes de la
liberté d'expression en réalité en
europe donc il ya peut-être des choses
qui sont en gestation et qui devrait
déboucher et je pense que c'est une très
bonne chose parce qu'on voit qu en
europe en effet nous on a ici indiqué
qu'on se sente et livre indépendant
c'est le cas d'énormément de pays en
europe il y en a d'autres qui se sentent
menacés moi je vois des collègues dans
certains pays de l'est qui l'a
contrairement à nous subissent des
vraies pressions
des pressions très fortes sur leur
personne sur leurs familles pour
transformer le média public en média de
propagande du gouvernement
donc c'est un c'est un vrai combat pour
la démocratie en fait que de combattre
pour maintenir l'indépendance de la
liberté d'expression en général et des
services publics en particulier
à monsieur center peut-être sur votre
autre
l'autre partie de votre question est
effectivement en france on a l'habitude
d'avoir une presse d'opinion qui est
soit très forte et très répandues médias
que la grande différence est que la
presse son achat soit l'unité soit par
abonnement et payant l'audiovisuel
d'accès qui est gratuit et donc c'est
une différence qui est absolument
fondamentale et jeu
pense que on perdrait beaucoup de notre
démocratie à avoir une tout et risation
de médias audiovisuels publics qui sont
le premier accès gratuit à l'information
pour beaucoup de nos compatriotes
premier accès gratuit à la culture aussi
et à du divertissement intelligent donc
c'est important et qu'il y aura des
espaces de débats qui soient les plus
fédérateurs possible et qui
il faut que le contrat sur tout soit
clair quand j'achète mon journal je sais
ce que j'achète le contrat de lecture
est très clair il faut que quand on nous
regarde sa chaîne de télévision qu'on
écoute la radio il faut que le contrat
soit aussi clair et aujourd'hui nous
avons des autorisations de fréquences
par exemple pour faire de l'information
c'est ce qu'on fait sur france info pour
la culture sur france culture et on
c'est important que chacun reste dans
ses missions et dans celles dans
lesquelles il a été autorisé à utiliser
ces fréquences pour avoir un accès qui
soit en accès direct au public
si je peux me permettre même la
présidence il n'est pas exact il me
donne la présidente il n'est pas gratuit
la publicité vous parlez la publicité je
suis non je parle de la cap ah oui la
cape mais oui tout à fait la cape qui
est un élément important mais qui fait
de nos chaînes des médias qui sont des
médias d'offres et pas des médias de
demande donc ce qui là aussi doit nous
obliger à nous détacher d'une logique
d'audience et donc de chercher à adhérer
à un bon moment ou un autre c'est
d'ailleurs toute la vertu d'un système
de financement public comme celui de la
cape qui ne pousse pas des logiques de
rentabilité ou de chercher à faire de
l'audience à tout prix
et qui sont justement un mécanisme de
financement qui nous permet de jouer ce
rôle très différent sur
ce qu'on a pu développer sur
l'innovation sur le caractère fédérateur
dernière précision
monsieur patino l'a dit tout à l'heure
ça nous renvoie au triptyque payant
gratuit services publics
n'ont pas exactement s'il est si vous me
permettez c'est je crois que que comme
l'a dit sybille il faut que le contrat
soit clair et on essaie de la voir
aujourd'hui pourquoi il ya une
multiplication des d audiovisuel
d'opinion c'est parce que l'opinion ça
coûte moins cher à faire que
l'information etc évidemment dans le
modèle de l'économie d'attention quelque
chose qui à la fois coûte moins cher à
faire et attire plus d'attention et
économiquement plus rentable et c'est la
ligne j'allais dire de pente naturelle
alors je dis pas de du côté de kehl où
quelle opinion mais le média d'opinion
et la ligne j'allais dire la pente
naturelle de l'économie de l'attention
financé par la publicité ça il faut le
savoir ça coûte moins cher ça rapporte
plus d'audience parce que ça attire
l'opinion donc évidemment c'est la ligne
de fuite
les services publics comme comme l'on
dit à la fois et delphine et sybille
enfin vraiment delphine ernotte et
sybille veille ça échappe à cette
logique là donc il faut que notre
contrat soit extrêmement clair pour
échapper à cette attention mais nous ne
sommes ni l'un ni les uns ni les autres
financé par l'économie de l'attention ne
sommes financés vous l'avez dit par la
collectivité et donc à ce titre là la
collectivité elle s'engage à moyen long
terme donc nous échappons j'allais dire
cet effet magnétique de l'économie de
l'attention et donc normalement nous
échappons je pense à la logique de
l'opinion donc le contrat je pense pour
chacun de nous il est clair moi très
rapidement si je dois vous le rappeler
pour arte la philosophie c'est les
enjeux pas le jeu ou le débat pas le
combat la forme c'est une chaîne de
récit documentaire fiction cinéma dont
qui échappe aux tables
aux tables de clash d'opinion et la
culture propre c'est une culture
européenne avec le décentrement des
regards qui fait que oui on a une valeur
arte on n'a pas d'opinion mais on a une
valeur notre valeur à les européennes
elle est donnée par le traité
interétatique le e2 art essai europe
donc on est franco allemand a visé
européenne ça c'est notre valeur
évidemment une valeur d'ouverture mais
je pense encore une fois que justement
le triptyque que vous avez l'amitié de
rappeler nous permet justement
d'échapper à cette logique là du média
du média d'opinion
non je voulais je réagisse et quand vous
disiez le devise elle n'est pas gratuit
c'est une convention tout est payant au
fond on pourrait dire aussi que l'école
n'est pas gratuite que l'hôpital n'est
pas gratuit
disons que tout comme l'ensemble des
services publics c'est en effet financé
par la collectivité mais à ce titre on
est tout de même gratuit au sens où
le personne n'a payé outre ce qu'il
verse à l'eau à la collectivité
d'abonnements supplémentaires et par
ailleurs je rappelle quand même que
beaucoup de foyers sont exemptés de
cette redevance donc à une forme de
déquilibre en fait également qu'ils se
trouvent qui ce qui s'opère entre les
foyers les plus modestes et comme
l'impôt sur le revenu finalement 1 et
essaie d'établir cet équilibre voilà
donc à ce titre comme tout service
public je pense qu'on peut revendiquer
le fait d'être gratuit comme l'école ou
l'hôpital
monique de marco oui je vous remercie je
vais faire très court puisque notamment
peu de temps donc moi je partage l'idée
cette nécessité d'un service public fort
accessible à tous qui innovent et qui a
des moyens financiers pour cela pourquoi
qu'il ya eu des baisses par exemple pour
france télévisions pour le budget 2022
donc et pour tout le monde aussi mais
j'avais remarqué 14 millions pour france
télévisions lors de l'audition devant la
commission culture en novembre
novembre 2021 madame la ministre dans
creuser une bâche l'eau a annoncé vous
en avez parlé de la création d'une offre
numérique partagé entre radio france et
france télévisions c'était pour le
premier semestre 2010 22
bon je n'ai pas obtenu de réponse à
cette période c'est en novembre mais
vous en avez abordé ceci suite aussi la
question dans ce domaine mans sylvie
robert pouvez vous nous apportez donc
des informations sur la mise en place de
cette plateforme son père y met son
financement et son fonctionnement est ce
ce projet du numérique dont vous allez
parler ou quelque chose de plus large
plus vaste de l'assist quelques
précisions puisque c'est aussi des
innovations de mot de passe
en fait on y travaille ardemment
ensemble avec sybil vane donc n'hésite
pas à compléter mais pour nous la date
du premier semestre est toujours la
bonne mais on la voit comme le début en
fait d'un travail non il y aura une
première proposition en mars et on le
voit comme le début d'un travail
d'enrichissement de cette offre de
proximité on va aussi apprendre ce que
c'est quand même assez neufs de procéder
ainsi parce que c'est une offre qui se
veut globale qui rapporte le meilleur de
radio france le meilleur de france
télévisions dans mon quartier près de
chez moi qui se rapportent en fait à mes
centres d'intérêt immédiat et à ma
géographie immédiate donc c'est assez
nouveau et donc j'espère bien que ça va
évidemment évoluer dans le temps que ce
faisant comme souvent dans le numérique
d'ailleurs on apprend en faisant et on
va en cheminant ensemble travailler
ensemble à enrichir de plus en plus à
partir de mars donc c'est pour ça que je
voulais dire ça à partir de mars cette
offre numérique de proximité
ah oui oui je vous confirme
oui tout à fait
sur ces questions effectivement c'est un
projet dans lequel on croit beaucoup de
chaque côté du côté des équipes de radio
france de france et des visions s'est
investi beaucoup parce que comme le
rappelait très justement delphine
ernotte on voit à quel point le besoin
de médias locaux et tous aujourd'hui
important pour créer un lien qui sont un
lien de proximité réelle dans un moment
où on est écrasé par les chiffres des
faits qui ont une dimension là pour le
citoyen pas toujours facilement
perceptible donc on est vraiment
soucieux de développer cette offre est
une offre de médias de la vie locale qui
ait une dimension
qui doit avoir toute sa dimension
numérique et qu'il nous permet en
joignant nos moyens de faire quelque
chose d'encore plus ambitieux c'est à
dire qu'on met ensemble nos forces nos
moyens d'investissement pour avoir une
offre qui puisse permettre d'apporter ce
que chacun de notre côté on pourrait pas
aussi bien développés c'est des
fonctionnalités nous parler delphine
ernotte
comment être géolocalisé comment prévoir
de l'interactivité sur ce type d'offre
pas vraiment aller au bout de cette
proposition là et c'est un projet que je
pense un très beau projet qui doit
marquer là encore l'utilité du service
public parce que il sera aussi
d'expression de la présence sur
l'ensemble du territoire de nos deux
réseaux
moi j'avais deux questions pour voir
vous poser pour finir sur la bord la
notion de qualité de l'information est
revenu les uns et les autres dessus on
comprend bien que vous êtes attaché à la
qualité de l'information ça c'est
d'ailleurs partie des missions du
service public bon ceci dit depuis que
nous avons commencé ses auditions
personne ne nous a dit aucun des
éditeurs ne nous a dit on fournit une
information qui est de mauvaise qualité
est ce que vous pourriez nous aider à
définir ce que qu'est une information de
qualité vous qui êtes des professionnels
comment vous caractériseriez la notion
de l'information de qualité et deuxième
question qui est un peu lié je crois que
ces monomères ernotte qui avait précisé
qu' il fallait
en cas de d'émergence de grands de
grands groupes notamment du fait de la
fusion possible tf1 et m6 qui est un
régulateur fort
est ce que ça voulait dire qu'il
faudrait renforcer les pouvoirs de l'art
comme notamment sur les deux aspects de
la qualité de l'information et du
respect du pluralisme et si c'est le cas
sur quels points particuliers
faudrait-il renforcer les pouvoirs de
l'art comme
c'est presque une question philosophique
que vous posez la sur qu'est-ce qu'une
information de qualité qui mérite
répondre rapidement et
interrompt s'est passé c'est pas pour un
débat philosophique c'est plutôt pour
voir si ça s'écrit dans une loi
alors ma réponse va être un petit peu
compliqué à écrire dans une moi je vous
dit pourquoi parce que d'abord il ya
bien des conditions nécessaires qui ne
sont pas pour autant suffisant que les
conditions nécessaires c'est que
l'information quand on la publie elle
soit vérifiée sur tous ses aspects
et donc ça demande du travail en fait
qu'à une vérification qu'ils soient
opérés deuxième chose c'est qu'elle soit
mise dans son resituer dans son contexte
et donc il faut aussi d'écrire dans quel
contexte cette information arrive et
enfin il faut aussi qu'elle soit
certaine manière décoder c'est à dire
qu'est ce que qu'est-ce que ça dit cette
information qu est ce que ça ne dit pas
si ça doit dire quelque chose donc il ya
une profondeur de champ de cette
information qui doit être travaillé
avant qu'elle puisse être publié une
certaine manière ça ce sont des
conditions nécessaires mais pas
suffisantes pour nous la condition
absolue c'est ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure madame c'est la confiance que
nos téléspectateurs ont dans cette
information dire que pour nous une
information n'est de qualité que si elle
à tous les critères qui sont sûrement
perfectible en eux que je viens de vous
annoncer un peu trop rapidement mais
surtout si les gens font confiance à
l'information qu'on leur donne alors à
l'article qu'on publie sur france info
au sujet qu'on présente au journal de 20
heures le critère ultime à la fin c'est
ça
je crois que l'art comme qui est né au
1er janvier a déjà cessé pouvoir
énormément renforcé et notamment dans le
champ de contrôle des
des médias globaux qui n'était pas le
sien aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut
continuer à miser sur un arc comme fort
et et renforcer encore son sont
certainement je pense que la régulation
indépendante ce que ce que l'art comme
est un lieu absolument essentiel pour
nous tous de régulation de l'audiovisuel
donc alors dans quel sens ça il faudrait
je peux pas vous répondre là en deux
mots mais certainement
de la même manière d'ailleurs que la
régulation européenne aussi se renforcer
donc il peut y avoir plusieurs niveaux
de renforcement de la régulation à une
échelle européenne et à une échelle
nationale
c'est juste pour dire que sur la
question de la régulation c'est pour
nous un enjeu qui va être vraiment envie
d'ajouter qu'il faut on a beaucoup fait
ces dernières années le lycée peur à
beaucoup faire on est sorti d'une forme
de naïveté à l'égard des relations avec
les grands acteurs que sont les gaffes à
il faut continuer parce qu'en permanence
on se retrouve dans des situations on
peut être évincé disrupt et c'est le cas
dans tout à l'heure
bruno patino parler des télécommandes je
vous ai parlé d un ca de connecter des
tableaux de bord des véhicules donc en
permanence il faut avoir une vigilance
dans ce monde de fortes innovations pour
faire en sorte que les contenus qu'ils
ont un intérêt général puisse continuer
à être accessible au citoyen et ses
comptes et une cure à l'intérêt général
sont de nature publique comme ils
peuvent être aussi nature privée et
c'est important de continuer à voir ce
cette vigilance sur la régulation
nécessaire aujourd'hui
juste en deux mots sur la régulation on
voit bien que
la philosophie de la régulation on la
comprend bien mais avoir le critère
précis sur lequel ça se définissent est
de plus en plus compliqué donc peut-être
que là et à une évolution petit à petit
du type de régulation enfin dans le mode
de suivi parce que effectivement
peut-être un an avant qui se faire des
télécommandes arrive on est à mille
lieues d'imaginer que ça va arriver
pourtant ça arrive et etc etc et le
numérique qui fait kiffer briser les
silos en fait fait qu'à un moment donné
votre poids dominant il peut être
dominant sur une opinion ou sur la
j'allais dire sur la fabrique de
l'opinion sur la fabrique du
consentement est donc là ça pose un
problème alors que c'est très difficile
à définir j'allais dire ex ante et sur
la qualité de l'information ce qu'a dit
évidemment delphine ernotte est tout à
fait juste quand on regarde les études
qui sont faites aujourd'hui on a
évidemment une impossibilité absolue
d'avoir l'indicateur ultime si j'ose
dire qui vous permettrait de savoir mais
il ya quand même deux corrélation qui
existe est malgré tout quoi qu'on en
dise la première chose c'est malgré tout
le nombre de journalistes dans une
rédaction alors quand on est dans un
média généraliste c'est le nombre de
jeunes de journalistes ou cours contre
un média spécialisé c'est le nombre de
journalistes sur cette spécialisation
c'est pas forcément les énormes
rédaction une information peut être de
très grande qualité si sur un sujet
donné j'ai quinze personnes qui sont sur
ce sujet donné mais malgré tout le
nombre de personnes professionnels dont
c'est le métier qui travaille sur la
fabrique de l'information ça veut dire
qu'on aura à priori plus d'informations
que de commentaires plus de
plus de vérification factuel plus de
connaissances ou autre et évidemment le
deuxième point c'est le degré de
compétences professionnelles des gens
qui forment ces rédactions là malgré
tout il ya une corrélation entre la
qualité de formation des gens qui font
la formation leur nombre et
l'information qui est produite c'est pas
une garantie ultime c'est pas comment
dire une le seul indicateur mais ça a
quelque chose et donc on peut se dire
qu'à un moment donné dans des endroits
où il ya de moins en moins de
journalistes et de gens de plus en plus
de gens qui font du contenu et qui
épouse du contenu a priori ce qui vont
pousser sera de moins en moins une
information sans doute de plus en plus
une opinion et sa qualité c'est à dire
sa qualité civile qu'un le fait de nous
transformer de publicans citoyen sera
sans doute moins forte
si dernière question du raccordement
sera faite à 17h30 mais oui alors une
question précise parce que je n'ai pas
été
satisfait madame r note parce que j'ai
vu comment de façon très solennelle vous
m'avez répondu à la question sur les
pressions politiques
par contre j'ai posé une question
précise sur
des annonceurs qui aurait arrêté leurs
budgets publicitaires
parce que des informations des
enquêtes auraient été mis sur le service
public
j'ai en tête ce qui s'est passé avant
même votre votre mandat mais qui s'est
poursuivie par des procédures
judiciaires
ici devant la commission monsieur
nicolas théry président du crédit mutuel
a absolument contesté
formellement le fait qu'ils aient eu
intervention une baisse des budgets
publicité de la banque mutualiste france
télévisions en réaction à la diffusion
du documentaire de nicolas vesco vinci
vous me confirmer ses propos où vous
pouvez même les infirmer en tous les cas
j'ai posé une question précise vous avez
répondu par une généralité sur le fait
que vous êtes attaqué en justice par
plein de gens et c est que vous ne
subissez pas la pression mais là je
parle de pressions économiques concrètes
en retrait depuis baisse du budget
publicitaire y en a jamais eu oui on a
eu
ce serait pas vous dire de bêtises parce
que je parle sous serment
je crois qu'il ya souvent menaçant fait
parce que parfois
certains responsables peuvent être en
colère parce que ils ont vu à la
télévision un reportage qui leur
convient pas et ils sont sincères
d'ailleurs souvent dans leur colère en
donc parfois ils peuvent dire alors
passé mais est-ce que ça a été
réellement fait je ne n'ai aucun
souvenir de toute façon ça n'est pas un
argument pour nous c'est à dire que la
publicité évidemment compte dans notre
dans nos revenus ça représente à peu
près 15 % mais mais mais ça n'est pas
fondamental
la liberté d'informer les beaucoup plus
donc
même je dirais que non mais ça me donne
des informations sur les pratiques
possibles d'abus de pouvoir économique
la puissance financière survient alors
le projet je vais dire autrement si
demain une puissance économique me
disais si vous faites ce reportage je ne
supprime la publicité ça ne changerait
pas d'un iota la publication de la
question c'est est-ce que ça a eu lieu
non je crois en tout cas alors je vais
répondre autrement parce que
est-ce que j'ai souvenir d'un d'une
baisse de chiffre d'affaires
publicitaire liée à un reportage
d'investigation
non en fait je m'en souviens pas mais
des menaces souvent vous avez au oui ça
arrive parce que moi je
j'ai souvent les gens au téléphone et
pour eux ce sont des hommes et des
femmes et je peux le comprendre aussi un
savez moi quand on dit que le service
public n'est pas la hauteur je suis pas
toujours content que non plus donc donc
voilà donc ça reste des conversations
privées qui n'ont pas forcément de
conséquence est en tout cas ça n'est pas
un ça n'est clairement pas un moyen de
pression sur france télévisions voilà
enfin merci d'accord j'ai revenir
l'année remarque aussi y vraiment
concerts et là je ne parlais pas de 6 à
prêter à conséquence ou de colère
exprimée parce qu'il n'y a pas d'accord
et je parlais de pression sur baisse de
budget aux pressions de menaces de
pression de ce type concrètement la dent
de menaces franchement non
l'expression de colère oui de menaces
non merci de vos réponses et de vos
interventions évidemment si vous voulez
éventuellement développer tel ou tel
point par écrit qu'on n'a pas pu compte
tenu du format table-ronde
entendre suffisamment sur un point que
vous auriez souhaité développer bus vous
pouvez bien sûr apporté des
contributions est décrite merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup et chers collègues on se
donne deux trois minutes
de pause ça peut-être profiter pour eric
aérer la pièce d'ailleurs ça serait
peut-être pas mal
[Musique]